i do have a room where in your home you
go to where you want to you know write
music chill out do your thing is there
some sort of fun room that's uniquely
yours no
uh that sort of sacred space is like the
shower that's where like some of my best
songs come from so what happens if
you're taking a shower and you hear uh
you know happy coming through your head
and you're like oh my god i hear this
great song do you run out of the shower
and sing it into a tape recorder how do
you do it you memorize it you do yeah
and are you of the theory that if i if i
don't memorize it that means it probably
wasn't that good uh yes and then no
there are some times where you forget
something and you're like never going to
remember that color again like there's a
specific color that just fits so
perfectly you think of music as colors
right i mean that's kind of like how you
you you kind of see it most musicians do
yeah so i'm not anything special and
most artists do you fall in love with
the people you write music with you have
to sort of vibe with that person just
love them so much when you work with
them in the studio it's got to be like a
love fest right no there's an energy
exchange so
and this let me see the best way i can
describe it it's like when don't you
know like when you're standing there and
you haven't heard one thing but you know
when someone's standing somewhere in the
room behind you you can feel it right
right okay yeah or you walk in a room a
complete stranger you don't know them
they've not made a face nothing in the
body gesture you just know when they
don't like you or you know when this
person likes you or you know this person
is checking you out but you never see
them looking at you that's a vibe that's
an energy we can feel those things right
right so when i walk in the studio with
someone they walk in they often walk in
with the vibe they have they have
something on them you know in the same
way that they may have a smell from
where they just came from they also have
a vibe about them that vibe is readable
then they also come in and they say
secondly they say what they're looking
for
so you know i want something that sounds
like this xyz blah blah blah blah or not
and then third
they have a voice
and if a person has like a satin voice
and used to sing into satin tracks my
job is to bring the juxtaposition and if
i can make
polka dots work with plaid then i've
done my job so if i was working with you
i shouldn't be inhibited when i walk in
and go this is what i really have in my
head this is what i'm thinking you
wouldn't be offended by that if i came
in with a really strong attitude and a
really strong point of view
yeah i take my the ego's hat off at the
door that's good so to allow for you to
be the champion in the room and then
that i get the best performance out of
you because that is the weird part of
your job because you're always
collaborating with different people you
got to sit there and work these people
into with their emotional problems and
everything else
the whole package you know and that's
why bands break up all the time because
people fight they have all kinds of
battles in a way you get out before all
that [ __ ] goes down where are you where
you have to yeah because if you get in
the way
well then now you're like sort of
changing like
you're changing the day and sometimes
you do have to come in and sort of
corral things back into order because
they can run rampant when you're working
with snoop you got to get high right i
mean it's almost like mandatory dude
dude
dude
i have to say
drop it like it's hot all those records
those were records that were born out of
just like contact situation
but the other day yeah because we're
working on his new his new record bush
right um
the other day
he
was the whatever the aroma was
i wanted to crawl under the desk
and stay there
for a while
do you ever say to him listen snoop i'm
working with you here i'm trying to keep
my wits about me no because that was his
that was his that was his world he
needed and it and let me just tell you
something it is a masterful experience
to work with snoop so you put up with
his idiosyncrasies his his vibe is
unbelievable
his zen is unbelievable
he's
and he's just wise in his perspective in
the way that he sees things see what i
mean you got to kind of fall in love
with the person you're working with you
have to yeah to some degree but his just
his energy is just unbelievable